hey your regularly scheduled programming
will start in a minute my half-asian
alert bill Richmond is here wanted to
give you an update some news we have
some news so if you remember our dr.
Trump video was taken down a copyright
claim Digital Millennium Copyright Act
claimed by warner/chappell and it's over
it's back up you can go see the video it
is back up that means that there are no
strikes on our channel and we're going
to re-upload it because we uploaded a
separate clip with a new intro some more
updates coming next week thank you guys
so much of course your support of mug
clubs what makes this possible and to
have this very expensive lawyer on
retainer and that will be moving to a
new space here as well updates on that
and then we'll be doing more Golden
Tickets hiring golden ticket hire rings
I don't know enjoy the show
lahter with Crowder studios protected
exclusively by Walter and Harper
maverick here preparing to pursue target
talk to me quarterblack Cruz
Roger that quarter black goose here you
give them hell I got your six
okay I have target luck we see this as a
while threat you bet your sweet ass Jack
Dorsey engaging target Roger that
maverick
[Music]
damnit missed him maverick so you have
company on your tail
we need Zuckerberg get here as long as
there are people spreading this
information this is going to be an
ongoing country will this complicates
things
seems like my invite got lost in the
mail too cute man telling to put the
same oh nice now the party started
I gotta call some boys we're trying to
do a woman's job
yeah yeah I heard it all before
they show you going so really does
Oh
looks like you ever would you see on
your fine
we have Community Guidelines to anything
that promotes hate we will take it down
this day just keeps getting better and
better
so sure shaker oh shoot
locked onto me
I hear you boys ordered a half asian
ass-kicking half agent longer bill rich
half asian lawyer bill Richman
you son of a don't worry boys I got this
that's what I'm talking about
looks like you just got suckered bird
John man go get some
hey Jack you know the difference between
precedents and precedents I don't have
answers to that cuz I'm about to set one
right on your ass
[Applause]
he got all of that one never gonna mark
oh hey Susan you ordered no MSG right
yeah I hear it's bad for your health
you know it's worse me don't worry boys
looks like I'm gonna have to do this the
old bag
[Applause]
oh my god oh my god
half a spoiler bill Ridge will talk to
me
do you read me Happy's lawyer village
you boys I think you can get rid of me
that easy to do preparation bill you're
alive yeah we thought you were a goner
half-asian Phil admits all those
billable hours I'm just glad you're okay
just checked your laddie Longo looks
like you'll be landing in palo alto
before beer o'clock
hello Alto
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that's called the man who took the old
KFC ads - literally you're not supposed
to actually consume your fingers Harold
we have been Shapiro on the show
versatile walk out content has some
opinions between yours in third chin of
course is a half Asian Larry pill rich
but now are you hello friends thank you
very much
how are you what sundown and that's
terrible embarrassed time no it's not
don't give him your vol Rose a my friend
yellow doesn't think at all it is pink
I think it's turned the idea that wine
only gets better don't agree with it
what's your question today what's been
your experience here with the recent
abortion bills discussing it seems like
people just want to their minds are
exploding on social media but I don't
know what it's been like for you in the
day-to-day and what do you think about
the Alabama and Georgia abortion laws oh
you're yeah I give it away where there
you go I was trying to foreshadow here's
like this is how it ends
yeah exactly I just skip to the end man
let's give all right this week Elizabeth
Warren refused to Fox News Town Hall on
fight Casey didn't know about what we're
gonna be talking about the abortion lied
or nobody said that the question into
your own blew the whole deal off okay
this comes from flipping over 2020
candidate denounced the cable network as
a quote hate for profit racket that
gives a megaphone to racists when I
arsenals
instead she doing more low-key town
halls like this random clip you see on a
bus
that literally you don't have to be yes
that's jail this is looking embarrassed
for her she's just like you yeah her
Instagram was my wife's favorite thing
and if ever I walk by the living room my
wife is going Liz both warns Instagram
she goes yeah and the hodgetwins just
commented on it this is why they made
the word cringe if you listen we
actually have an exclusive audio with
different angles and if you listen that
everyone was thrilled
[Music]
[Music]
turning to entertainment PBS is Arthur
mr. Ratburn the teacher came out as gay
and got married on the season 20
premiere yes comes from TV line the news
comes out an episode titled mr. Ratburn
and the special someone
this comes as little surprise to most
with longtime fans and they're setting
mr. Edwards obsession with cleanliness
fashion in episode 246 mr. Ratburn gets
AIDS oh that one was which I think he
also controversial II joined Isis which
seems as though it was kind of a
giveaway yeah
[Music]
so what what is that I don't know we
just found enough in the studio Oh
sister call button let's go yeah in
international news free bikes are being
given out to fat people by the NHS let's
come to the mirror in the UK their
regular cycling is more effective at
cutting the risk of heart disease and
many drugs so the NHS is giving out bike
rides based on a on a prescription basis
so buddies are praising the Move Fitness
though they're actually detractors
claiming that this quote further
stigmatizes fat people with others
complaining that quote these bikes taste
like we're too stupid to live at some
point like all these like salt
regulations and sugar regulations is
like they're doing everything they can
to make us stick with international news
business and center they just recently
published a profile on Mohammed bin
Salman the crown's Prince he's become a
controversial figure
particularly in a fall of 2018 when he
faced a global outcry over the death of
course of Jamal - eggy we don't want to
judge though he's trying to reform Islam
and that's very challenging to ask a
sponsor to the show and we're very
grateful of course that will have no
effect at all in our editorials no
according to vice by the way it's
problematic that medical textbooks
overwhelmingly use pictures of young
white men this is the latest so
according to the author depicting the
same body over and over again as white
male and athletic isn't the best way to
teach future doctors she pointed to
renowned medical journals that have been
published such as the New England
Journal of Medicine the Journal of aging
in health and the DSM 14 words which
seems like that's not the guy who's
there to help you
Oh oh my gosh you know if it was full of
black guys be like that's right another
black brother dead in a book you just
showing dead black guys what they would
have a problem either what are you
talking about exactly what he's doing
now now now say I don't think you get
what the 14 words are you wouldn't have
tied that bit there oh I mean I didn't
go to medical school but I'm pretty sure
a lot of those pictures or guys without
skin on but I could tell those muscles
look white matter I have no idea it's
not white so you can tell by the tibias
finally a child just covered in the gate
notably that it's slow Wow child
discovered $40,000 worth of meth inside
a box of Legos what yes comes from this
comes from Huffington Post because
that's that's that's about what we use
yeah for ah that's what they're for and
really honest they actually they found
the box at a consignment shop and they
gave it to a small child who opened the
box according the article was likely
very disappointed
or was he I'm not convinced
[Music]
for the first time Lego has joined
forces with methamphetamine so that you
too can save the world
[Music]
Lego methamphetamines yes your stuff
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
because we have a new YouTube channel if
you want to subscribe to a router bits
it's a YouTube channel I didn't name
please upload that'll probably go up
there just a lot of you been asking for
bits sketches or kind of short segments
that maybe sometimes you want to share
and you don't want to necessarily use a
whole show so let us know what you want
to see up at Crowder bits again I didn't
name it last week trivia contest winner
was tymberlee Rygel who correctly
graduates significant other is Josephine
that's right so we're gonna be sending
you a t-shirt and half-asian bills
helmet isn't hot gun helmet because they
don't send that that's a great helmet I
know no no I don't it's very different
you did a great job Porter black girl he
does a lot of the props put the Hat up
the one in the two are very far to go to
see there it is none of them were girls
by the way you're wrong they're all
disappointed so I do ever want to hear
from you I'm really good at that
half-asian lawyer at pillars miss you
because we'll be talking about the
abortion laws this is running for two
days now and of course Georgia and
Alabama there's been so so much
misinformation out there it really has
been driving me nuts I don't just want
to say oh it's driving me crazy it's
wrong I want to let you know as to why
it's incorrect and I want to know what I
guess intellectual fallacies you've seen
most out there so here a couple of
claims that I've seen most one of them
let's go right off the bat they've been
claiming everywhere by the way and aoc
kind of claimed it but it was
said they misinterpreted her tweet I
don't know I'll give it water line you
don't need a OC on this one because
everyone else has been saying that these
laws constitute jailing women for murder
if a Georgia resident plans to travel
elsewhere to obtain an abortion when she
comes back she could face ten years
imprisonment
don't you mean abortion without one city
Tannen once said party yeah whom are you
gonna imprison every woman who's had a
fertilized egg passed through her no you
just I don't know mr. the mechanical
engineer guy but specifically because
they've kind of thrown in Georgia and
Alabama yeah okay they both make
specifically criminalize the act of
performing the abortion outside of the
listed parameters exactly that we're in
a difference they're just actually
calling abortion what it is right
they're calling abortion something that
is is ending a human life now right
there might be a penalty for performing
that well I want to they very clearly
expressed banning the or the it's the
person is performing the abortion what
brings us actually their subsequent
claim that the Georgia billet claim has
loose language that could maybe lead to
the prosecution of women who take an
abortion pill or who travel to other
states or who even miscarry this is one
we've been hearing a lot yeah
miscarriage gender this these lots
stupidest that well here's the thing
yeah and I've been doing a lot of
research since 4:00 in the morning so
I'm not that sharp today but even in
this scary old pseudo handmade tale days
I know it's this post-apocalyptic future
but I don't I stopped watching after
episode two okay hurry I couldn't shoot
bang and Dante Draper
that's where I know her if you go back
to let's say a real room before roe v
wade okay maybe hearing me say I don't
want to get bogged down in the details
crappy show I've only been you recorded
incidents of women being charged with
any kind of crime associated with their
abortion okay one was in 1911 and one
was in 1922 throughout the unless I'm
wrong Arthas throughout the entire
history of an American Western law only
one woman was ever charged with the
crime of self abortion that specific
crime 1599 you have to go back one 1500s
no woman ever in the history of ma
Western law as far as I know let me
offer has been charged with a crime for
miscarrying yeah I've not seen it am i
do you know if it again
fifty ninety-nine one time was well you
know what maybe the row v Wade people
weren't being locked in the slammer
because they were taking a pill that's
not what what's happening you gotta kind
of reach far back to find something like
that 15 million n that's crazy the
argument that would be made to it is
like oh my gosh they're gonna have
back-alley abortions and she's people
are gonna do self abortions now so that
they can get around it look I would
rather deal I know this is gonna sound
harsh I would rather deal with
back-alley issues I would rather deal
with people wanting to do their own
abortions and find ways to figure that
out then deal with a killing spree that
we have right now right I would rather
do those things
look if you are so afraid I don't know I
don't want to deal with any of it so are
you going to take that context and say
oh you're saying you want better no I'm
not saying that I want back-alley oh I'm
saying if you're giving me a choice of
immortality rates for pregnant women
up until roe v wade is very very low
they were not a lot of self performed
abortions did it happen yeah but it's
not like that what was that to me more
film I just forgot it it's something
about how she's talking about yeah
there's a house and all the different
women had abortions yeah the whole
family
exactly but look I think I think if you
are so scared that you're willing to go
out and have an abortion by a doctor
that you have no idea if it's clean if
it's sanitary if it's safer you're
willing to try to perform an abortion on
yourself maybe stop before having sex or
use contraception this is not rocket
super sad impactful for you
sounds to you like you're condoning rape
bill look so nothing hitting your light
there or no what did I no no legally
he's wrong but I'm right there with you
in the terms of if you if if you have a
legitimate concern about people
performing self abortions illicit let's
say that you want you see abortion has
one of those options so that they can do
it in a safe clean environment but you
should also be in favor of the other one
of their other ways to prevent abortions
from happening or being necessary yeah
such as abstinence or through or other
yeah contraceptives that type of thing
and so you know I get it there's there's
definitely gonna be some on the on the
right who've said that they're against
contraceptives because it encourages sex
and that's one view it's not a
mainstream view it's not mainstream do
it but that's the point is that you know
but but it's not okay to be in favor of
abstinence or to say that abstinence is
a legitimate way to not have to
an abortion yeah the only legendary it's
the only gear absolutely doesn't work
abstinence only works yes I think you're
confusing you're moving the words around
I'm not saying we only teach people
about abstract if you do want to teach
them the only way to avoid an STD STI or
unplanned pregnancy the only way is
Thank You Alyssa Milano for the sex
strike next people from having to have
abortions right now Lubriderm in old
episodes of charm for her husband ah
sweetie you gave away too much to get
for free I could hold that like the
hockey strike hit the notifications Elsa
Midwesterners love that high bookmark
the page cuz notification bells don't
mean a whole lot if you're subscribed
not [ __ ] join mug club and iTunes
leave a review rating there yeah here's
another thing to the people been saying
that it's just right-wing extremism and
that it's completely unprecedented
that's actually from so on that all
evangelize don't try to put you in jail
for misc this actually this is something
I think people don't understand we have
pretty liberal laws regarding abortion
the majority of European countries
actually have abortion bans after 12
weeks and a lot of them require waiting
period after consulting with a doctor
yeah well I mean god forbid you have to
wait five days before you potentially
into human life and so there's some
really cool to stay with me for a second
Gallup did some really interesting
Studies on this everybody thinks that
the abortion is pro-choice is by far the
thing that people want no it's right
it's really about 48 48 right now you
don't even know that's using the most
broad terminal in the broad terminology
right so if you drill down people
actually say that they would rather have
it legal under some circumstances and
the people that are in favor 50% roughly
50% some circumstances around 29% say
under any so that's even a smaller group
the people that say under certain
circumstances 38 percent of that group
Plus throughout history back into the
early 90s said in very limited
situations if you drill down into the
numbers there are not that many people
out there who actually favor under any
circumstance abortions right but they
make you the media makes you think
they're just on Twitter so that's just
animal - margin of error and really just
Elizabeth Warren with a meat cleaver and
and baby at the end of the table
we eliminated her it skewed the polling
data
Rasmussen didn't think it was valid
that's a voter we won't get under stand
this though either at least it's
intellectually consistent for these
people who say abortion period on demand
no questions asked because it to me
either it's a tragedy or why should it
be rare exactly who cares why would you
want it to be does anyone want pap
smears to be rare no no they want doctor
checkups to be rare no they do I want
people removing swollen tonsils to be
rare no so I don't even it's an
appointee or who cares whether it's rare
so I'm glad that at least right now
we're having this conversation openly
and honestly another claim that you've
heard this is a big fear mongering claim
from the left and it's not entirely by
the way unfounded that this is going to
100% lead to the overturning of roe v
wade setting up a potential showdown in
the highest court of the land unless new
abortion law the strictest in our
country is setting up a direct challenge
to roe versus wade
donald trump said in the third debate
with hillary clinton though if i get two
or more appointments to the Supreme
Court automatically that's the word he
used automatically roe v wade will be
overturned and I think the president was
exactly right
Rovi without according to cabin on and
every woman in Alabama who gets pregnant
is gonna be forced to give birth soon
okay oh no people would like proceed
overturn yeah probably a lot now about
well we don't feel fact yes a lot in
Alabama that's a separate issue from the
argument this is a there's a few common
misconceptions about roe v wade and what
would happen if it were overturned down
okay all states place restrictions or
most states place restrictions
regulations and abortions outside of the
federal purview Texas they wanted to ban
abortion after 20 weeks yeah which
Elizabeth Warren famously opposed
because she's morally everyone has the
hell they're willing to die on what's
yours the hill littered with dead babies
yeah it's the dying hill that's why I
thought it was the most appropriate the
hill I want to dine is the dying Hill
Colorado make 34 weeks Virginia 25 weeks
and these laws often make it bill you
probably know about this half-asian bill
they make it to higher courts yes so
there's truth to that yeah they do I
mean the the the the case itself allow
to have different restrictions based on
the trimesters that was the kind of
fundamental writing a practical
application of it and so we have always
since Roe versus Wade had limitations
and really again I think who goes back
to your point which is where if you
really do think it's as easy as clipping
a nail and it's as you know morally
irrelevant as clipping a fingernail then
you should just be you're probably more
consistent to just say it should be
allowed always right and in these other
states essentially to say oh that Roe
versus Wade may be challenged well Roe
versus Wade was a is a very complex
opinion that sets different types of
restrictions at different trimesters and
it also has a certain basis in the
fourteenth amendment the right to
privacy and so you can you can maybe
partially explain that because that's
make a lot of people don't know they
think that roe v wade says there's a
constitutional right to abortion and
they think there in the Constitution
there's some interpreting right to
abortion so with what the Fourteenth
Amendment which was the basis of the
opinion is the saying that yes here you
have the Constitution through the Bill
of Rights which says or rather through
an amendment it wasn't in the Bill of
Rights but to say you can have a right
of privacy which that word isn't
actually there but it's interpreted as
one of the rights that are broadly
enumerated in the Fourteenth Amendment
and then from that derivative right
right to privacy you then have a defer
the derivative sub derivative right that
says that your body and being able to
you were going to do with your body so
and I think intellectually like you know
very high level a lot of people wouldn't
understand I mean there's a lot of you
know libertarian fans of the show who
would say your right to privacy allows
you to put in your body whatever you
want or to be able to do with your body
whatever you want so it's not like that
entire spectrum of our you know and by I
think that's a valid argument I think
that libertarians you say not only do I
think possibly illegal but I think
someone should be able to shoot heroin
in the house if they want to I think
it's very hard to argue against that
constitutionally and it's a compelling
argument and but the difference becomes
when for example it you have a different
heartbeat right now you're hurting
someone else in there and where you draw
a line again under the libertarian
philosophy you would draw a line where
you're hurting someone else and those
types of things yeah and and that's
where you you even on the question of
what you have a right to privacy before
your right to privacy doesn't extend to
what you can do - no I it's a really
really loose not tied there and yeah
even Ruth Bader Ginsburg who's likely
dead admitted who knows Robbie way
there's a byproduct of court heavy
judicial intervention ISM that's
she said okay so I want to make sure the
people are long words yes and she's
she's dead weekend at Bernie's all over
again
weekend Akins whatever you choose this
is this is more so a generalized
claiming her about abortion a lot but
they have been banging on all cylinders
when it comes to this one here's these
two laws specifically that this is about
regulating a woman's body there's no law
like this against men democratic woman
in the legislature tried to fight back
state senator vivian figures introduced
an amendment to make vasectomies a
felony noting that there are no laws
regulating what a man to do the body
this creature are you to tell me what to
do with my body it's my decision it's
not yours
hold a second men could have none in
what women do with their bodies so you
want to undo Robbie wait who wouldn't
who is Phil in the courts sweetheart huh
you want to lose the right to vote
because she gave you that one many of
you didn't even want it beauty in the
draft there by the way there are plenty
of laws like this that applied him in
here's actually something I'm asked this
can you name me genuinely a countable
instance where it doesn't so they could
her vasectomy right to the heartbeat
bill justice system it's your appendage
it's your DNA you can do what you want
with your body justice by the way no one
out there cares about you getting your
tubes tied
no what happened cares about getting a
pass where there's was this woman left
this was tweeting and twittering oh so
now we're gonna have laws about not
about men are gonna decide what we do
with their pap smears how often what a
second how do you think it is that none
of us care about any of those things
because the vasectomy is not ending a
heartbeat by the way not yours
another heartbeat so let me ask you this
if we all acknowledge when we're talking
about a heartbeat bill okay that you're
stopping a heartbeat and it's not the
moms heartbeat the mom doesn't have two
hearts she's not a medical marvel at
least most of them right well I would
the doctor ben Carson isn't gonna having
to come in and separate all of them
that's my question to you is if you're
ending a heartbeat whose heart whose
don't beat are you ending and can you
point me to any instance any any example
where a man can legally stop the
heartbeat of another human
innocent nonviolent let's not get into
war here came to me any example more
importantly can you name me one example
that would allow men to do that
exclusively meaning men were allowed
just men would be allowed to stop
someone else's heartbeat and women
wouldn't be that's the only way that
your argument holds water oh my gosh so
the other argument what about a man
should have an equal right if it's
equality right as opposed to just one
gender over the other or flipping the
script so that one is taking advantage
of the other right again if you even
assume that the opposite of true is true
would that mean that a man has an equal
right to say hey we had sex you
definitely have to take plan B if you
get in if you have a few you definitely
have to get rid of it I mean that but
that extension that right has to extend
to a man if it's if you're gonna follow
that track of it's her body how dare you
well alright I mean and then you say oh
well it's her body okay fine
there's a reason why I had to stop and
say stop its heartbeat stop her
heartbeat stop his heartbeat instead of
just saying stop all the heartbeats yeah
exactly well look look it's a great
point to talk about the heartbeat and
saying that it's a separate heartbeat
right because what we're dealing with
here is somebody who is saying every
part of my body is under my control and
this thing that is inside of me is not a
person right right yeah fine if you want
to have that argument in that debate
that's fine because at some point it
becomes a viable human being outside of
the womb we can talk about that well get
that's a whole macro this guy there's no
consistent line to draw it's out of
concept right yeah but I'm saying that's
fine but now with it with these
heartbeat bills what you're saying is
they're making a very fine point and
saying that's a second heartbeat that
you can't stop and think that it's just
a clump of cells it's not a clump of
cells anymore yeah that's that's where
the argument is now or we're all clumps
of cells and it doesn't matter right
exactly be rare denial who cares here's
something else that I that I genuinely
am curious to hear people's opinions I'm
because I asked my wife this the other
night women out there can you think of I
mean I'm sure women from a long time ago
can say sure because if I spoke out my
husband gave me a fresh one I understand
what right Wonderbread era let's talk
about today can you think of any issue
today where as a woman you are told
you're not allowed to have an opinion
exclusively because you're a woman if
we're gonna say oh that we're
vasectomies men could do it hold on a
second no men are not
to stop another human beings heartbeat
in any instance the only people who are
allowed to do that are women it's an
exception to the rule of the only
exception where it's permissible to end
another autonomous beings heartbeat is
for women so let me ask you on the
flipside are you ever told as a woman
that you cannot hold an opinion or you
are not entitled to an opinion
exclusively because you are a woman
women who are watching listen let me
know I can't think of any yeah could be
my male priviledge genuinely can anyone
here think of me my wife couldn't she
said I'm honestly I'm never told that I
can't have an opinion on any issues
she's a rape economics men's health yeah
and you check all of it well and this
was the the thing that she did at the
end where she was kind of crying and
pointing to the camera saying it's my
body it's not yours you could have used
that for slaves and people did it's my
property not yours
right right that's the same exact
argument that was being used and it was
bad then - and it's still bad now right
and so we do have to get to a Ben
Shapiro in a little bit but they're
claiming that these bills would imprison
mothers they won't these bills are
completely unprecedented they're not
these bills don't take into account the
health of the mother they do this is the
start of overturning roe v wade well not
exactly but potentially it's a
conversation we have but let me ask you
this what if none of this matters what
if these states two people here who are
upset about these bills particularly the
Elizabeth Warren's the yeah Kamala
Harris well the entire DNC platform yeah
of course there's no there's no
intellectual diversity there at all one
of these states let's say Georgia
Alabama had passed an abortion bill okay
that made exceptions for rape and incest
and the life of the mother they already
make that exception and they banned
abortion at only 12 weeks requiring a
five-day waiting period would liberals
support it do you think they'd support
it then or do you think you guys would
protested she and her husband did what
they thought was best for their baby
girl they got an abortion and the third
trimester reproductive rights are about
health they are about safety this is a
existential fight for the right and
existential body abortion just be
theoretically legal it has to be
literally accessible yeah I feel like
it's a basic human right that nobody
gets to use your body without your
consent about jamming for sex in it
I didn't want to become a mother it is a
normal part of women's medical lives so
far succeeding is limiting our access to
exercise our constitutional right it's
not a constitutional resident by the way
but these are the same people who don't
believe in the constitutional right to
keep and bear arms which actually is a
constitutional right it's actually
spelled out we're talking about
amendments it's number two right next to
number one which includes freedom of
speech which you also don't believe in
stepping you've heard of stepping over
dollars to pick up pennies you're
stepping over rights to grab ones that
don't exist let's move that over here
right to bear arms I don't really like
it because David hog wasn't a Michael
Moore film 14th Amendment's right to
privacy therefore you have an abortion
at 32 weeks says Elizabeth Warren guess
what I'm pretty confident on what it
really is absolutely remarkable to me by
the way I want to make sure that I'm
clear that context of the first
Elizabeth Warren clip she was talking
about parents with a late term abortion
because the baby was going to have a
congenital I believe a heart defect yeah
so I don't want to be accused of taking
out of context here's the thing it
doesn't matter that's not why she was
opposing a 20-week abortion ban you need
to understand this okay if they say hold
on a second we need exceptions on this
there's no exception for rape or incest
all right hold on a second you're
against a 20-week ban so how about on
the flip side would you only extend the
portion beyond 20 weeks in cases of rape
incest or for example a congenital heart
defect serious birth defects the health
of the mother that's not what Elizabeth
Warren proposed no no not at all they
don't make those exceptions you can't
have it on one side of the coin and not
on the other it really is remarkable to
me when and again the intellectual
consistency yeah-hoo-hoo who cares why
should it be rare exactly you should be
able to if it doesn't mean anything
and also the fear-mongering that really
bothered me to hear the right accused of
fear-mongering quite a bit where they're
the right fear boggers they want your
for that's based on fear be honest what
our conservators fear monger on okay
terror terrorism
socialism okay 9/11 Arab Spring
Isis
[Laughter]
that's fear-mongering what is it
climate change polar icecaps were
supposed to be gone by the way we're
supposed to at the entire world was
supposed to be in famine aside from
North America and parts of Europe 1111
years a Florida supposed to be gone no
more coral reef no more fish not saying
there's no climate change but the
catastrophe certainly haven't happened
right abortion if you ban abortion
you're gonna be you're gonna be jailed
for miscarrying so where is the right
fear mangas gives you a heads up based
on things that have actually happened
and are currently happening across the
world to let fear monitor some things
that can't be proven never happen they
move on to the next thing no one in this
country has been regularly arrested for
having abortions or for miscarrying the
if you accept that wholesale you have
bought false fear-mongering it's not
even close to the truth and at least we
can correct that we can get to the
conversation of abortion at large but
hopefully I've assisted you if I haven't
and I just wasted a lot of your time and
your public waiting for ben shapiro
anyways because gonna be a barn burner
my favorite small jewish man
[Music]
either you're mad and I don't play by
anyone's rules not YouTube's Twitter or
Facebook that's because I have only one
rule that I respect and that's I join
monthly you can join my club to be rebel
like me join up and have the freedom to
be your own man
[Music]
now I know what you're thinking did he
fire 14 rounds or 15
that's erroneous as my new Allsteel ppq
five-match as a 17 round magazine plus
one in the chamber
with the best ergonomics in the business
I'm capable of putting a shot right
between your eyes at 40 yards away so
you have to ask yourself one question do
you feel lucky well do ya punkk Lida
with router studios protected
exclusively by Walther
louder with prouder shop.com is now
selling baseball team in red blue and
mass get yours and bladder with quite a
shop calm today
[Music]
so yeah I don't care about you and I'm
dancing it's not a performance it's
about feeling the music move through me
namely my fingers
that's about pretty much WCW music
movement is limited to the fingertips
like an old like a father-in-law at a
wedding not my father-in-law very glad
to have our next guest I know that he's
a busy man and he's traveling around the
country so his time is limited his new
book the right side of history how
reason and moral purpose made the great
West he's been making the rounds talking
about it and I was a subject of a little
bit of controversy of which we'll talk
about mr. ben shapiro how are you sir
and then okay are you did i am i am
doing all right so i you know we were
talking before the break i never know
how to broach this subject so let me
kind up because you never know if it's a
sore spot like i talked with a fighter
one time and asked him about a fight
that was a loss for him and matsing this
is comparable in this in that sense but
he you could tell he got pissed and i
thought oh i thought that was a good
question if that was compelling and this
was a heavyweight who didn't like me
after that so this happened on the BBC I
think we have some b-roll here the guy's
name is a Neal Brennan
Andrew Neil Andrew Neil sure I said I
think Brennan Brennan was a fighter I
don't know who I'm thinking Neal Brennan
um so listen I think that a lot of the
criticism there has been lobby against
you obviously I think is unfair I think
some of it is constructive what's your
overall view on this since people been
talking about it yes I mean I think that
you know there are certainly some things
I regret about this interview I tweeted
out the stuff I regret about the
interview and then there's some stuff I
really don't regret about the interview
the stuff that I regret is you know I'm
in the middle of a book tour and we're
doing a lot of book interviews and the
producers for BBC approached us and they
said you know we want to have you on to
discuss the book and I figured okay
normal book interview even if it gets
you know a little bit antagonistic
that's that's totally fine I mean I just
did an interview with Vox where Sean
ihling opposes a lot of the ideas in the
book we did a long half-hour interview
about it because he was asking questions
about the books I figured okay no
problem it's a busy day so we sit down I
thought that was risky I'll say I read
the Box interview let me tell you I
thought it was risky because it was in
writing it wasn't a video and anytime
that happens especially with someone
like you or a lot of it is read through
tone I thought oh they could they could
make that a hatchet job but I actually
thought it came out pretty well but it's
it's not something I would do when I
know it's Justin yeah and I mean
honestly like I'd rather do live video
typically not even tape resin with the
you see but in any case you know so I it
was a lazy decision on my part I didn't
know anything about the guy who was
interviewing me I heard him my ear
obviously I have no idea who Andrew Neal
is I don't follow British politics all
that closely truthfully
so we sit down and we start the
interview and his opening question is
really antagonistic
he starts asking about the barbarity of
pro-life positions and he starts as
isn't this Georgia policy bringing us
back to the dark ages he
mischaracterizes the Georgia law itself
but I figure okay I Know Who I know who
this guy is obviously idiotic movie I
have no idea what the guy is that's the
entire problem and so I assume just like
any journalist you ask that sort of
question in the u.s. this person is on
the left well it turns out that Andrew
Neal is apparently famously on the right
there although I assume not on the
social right there so I start pushing at
him prodding at him there so mistake
number one didn't know who he is and
that was a mistake and you know you got
to own that I tweeted out even before
the interview aired that I had no idea
who he was I apologize for saying that
he was on the Left when he is not in
fact on the left I'm somewhat familiar
with him even though I just got his name
wrong I said no I never find out who
Neal Brennan is because Neal Brennan is
a person in his in my there's Chris
Brennan was a fighter who had trained
with once and then there's a guy named
Neal Brennan no idea where but I know
who he is a little bit because you know
I've seen Canada were a little bit more
closely tied with the but he is kind of
a dick so that that part you didn't get
wrong but continue right so so so that
brought us to the the second part of the
interview well he eventually starts
basically browbeating me with the idea
that I've said things that I regret in
the past well yeah I mean so have most
of us who've been in politics I have a
column that I reference twice in the
interview this this interview by the way
is about 16 minutes and so he he he
mentions all this stuff I mean I say
twice I've got an entire column it's
famous I posted it online
all about this sort of stuff that I've
said that I regret or that I've
explained and he won't allow me to
explain any of the comments and I start
to get frustrating this is when I make
the second thing that I regret which is
I went to the ego play so again based on
the assumption that this guy is just
some BBC schmuck and and not a famous
guy I I say you know well you know I'm
famous scene you're not which is always
a bad move always a dumb move and of
course I regret that one that was stupid
also now here's the thing I don't regret
there's no question he was badly
motivated I mean the entire line of
questioning was right you're a bad
person
I'm gonna smear you you're a bad person
if I start to answer he interrupts
you're a bad person over and over and
over here's all the bad things that
you've said and I keep saying yeah I've
said things I regret yeah here's how I
explain this one
he keeps referencing a column I wrote in
2012 I say can you ask me something from
the last five years or why don't you
read I don't remember everything I've
written well babe that exact same thing
he had his flashcards and he was
bringing up old tweets from you I mean
this is something they always do yeah
and again the thing was I wasn't in that
headspace so it's funny well like
Shapiro gets blown away in debate well
this was an interview but it was
scheduled as an interview like if he
were a debate you prepped like it's a
debate I wasn't prepped the failure of
preparation is my fault
so it successful ambush for him so win
for him here's the thing I don't regret
getting up and walking out I don't
regret for a heartbeat I do not regret
it for a second the fact is that he was
badly motivated he was looking for the
gotcha moment he he felt he got the
gotcha moment just by asking all these
questions and refusing to listen to the
answers he didn't ask a single question
about the substance of the book at all I
took him 17 minutes to get to the point
where he apparently was about to ask
that question and I felt like you know
what I have I do have a basic rule and
this is true in any conversation I've
said this a thousand times in my
speeches my basic rule is when someone
is intent on defaming your character you
have no obligation to continue with the
conversation that's what he was doing
Brennan so I was out and by the way this
this idea that this was just an honest
line of questioning his own producer
tweeted out after this whole thing was
over that this is why you should have
people like Shapiro on so that you can
basically attack their character I mean
it's we write that out himself
so yeah there's no kind of funny way
they're getting up and walking out
because again it was it was an ambush so
he gets a win for the ambush good can I
offer while I have you in a mode here
well I have you in a mode talking about
like the breaking gonna be okay if I
made that I may offer a little word of
it the only thing I would say about your
walkout this is the performance art of
it in my opinion if you're gonna walk
out walk out what like light off a big
old mouth cannon and walk away laughing
because at that point you were trying to
walk out respectfully you know you were
pissed but just be like no go yourself
and you walk that's how I think if
you're gonna walk out to me if you're
gonna walk out make it a serious walk
out just sort of slapping your doneger
on the table and this is the part that
always kills you I was trying to be
polite even at the end you know and then
I tried to be polite
after that by kind of joke
about okay well you got me ben shapiro
destroyed and all of that and apparently
politeness is is not invoked but again
i'll freely admit this one went like
crap for me it was not a great shot the
crap i just think that people are so
listen everyone people who don't enter
the arena they're always looking to
fault someone who does right they're
always looking for you to fall and I
would say it's certainly not your best
performance but I really think it was I
think the guy was being a dick yeah and
I don't think the left can have it both
ways where they say well on the BBC in
the UK or they talk about Canada I go oh
oh you're talking about unbiased
journalism in Canada where it's funded
by the government where our prime
minister literally promised a hundred
and fifty million dollars to the CBC if
he won surprised he won no no you can't
say that they're unbiased and it's true
journalism that they ask tough questions
and then have an interview where he
spends fourteen minutes on your Twitter
and not on the book that's also a
substance listen I agree with all that
but you know I figured that listen I I
hold myself to a higher standard and so
if I don't live up to that standard then
that's the way that it goes right I mean
that's that's my fault again my first
rule is you got to research the person
who are you debating my fault was I
didn't and so you get shown up if you
don't research the person you're
debating that's a mistake and you know
people time you know when it's like
Cinque you're like oh this is what you
know about you put Michael on Cinque you
were on stage with him and your own
audience started booing you when Ben was
debating you this is what bothers me is
is the dog is the pig pile on people or
people have said this about me because
we do change my mind which isn't a
debate they go when you're not debating
high school kids that go on a second
we've debated professors scientists on
the show right Naomi Wolf has come on
this show and you I know that you have
if people can run a search know this
this is now you're heading out a pet
peeve of mine which is all the media
coverage which was you know he'll debate
college students but as soon as he gets
in the ring okay
I can I've have had on the Sunday
special Andrew yang we discussed ubi we
were adversarial about it but friendly
I've had on Sam Harris I've had to
public debate with him on his own
podcast I was on Bill Maher's show I've
debated shank publicly aggregated black
lives matter publicly socialist Shama so
on publicly I've debated gun control
publicly I've debated more than pretty
much anybody that I know people on the
left and I have discussions with people
on the left so frequently that literally
the day that this interview was taped
that interview with Fox came out right
and again Sean ihling disagrees with me
but it was a perfectly nice cordial
conversation in which we decided to get
to the issues at the heart of the book
and I think by the way if you want an
informative back-and-forth on the book
that's a good place to start so you know
that
the interview you know no I feel bad cuz
I haven't asked a whole lot about the
book I'm the bad guy here I'm a communal
symmetry but I haven't asked about the
book tell us about the book because the
book obviously is about kind of how to
have these conversations for people who
don't know I think we have an overlay
here of your book yes I mean the book is
basically asking the question why is it
that we live in the most prosperous
freest time in world history and yet
we're sort of beating each other up and
the answer is that we don't have shared
fundamental Universal beliefs anymore
what were those shared fundamental
Universal beliefs at the heart of
Western civilization why are they good
why did they produce this good free
prosperous world and what are those
beliefs that we should be reacquainted
with and why did we lose those universal
principles so really is sort of a pop
history of philosophy and 250 pages or
less it's not the world's easiest read
but I think it's pretty informative and
pretty and pretty useful and I think it
answers some some important questions
more important questions than how about
this crappy tweety 720 times though
those questions can be funny and if they
were pull mine up I'll just have to my
response will just have to be something
I would say yeah that's pretty bad
that's why I'll never run for office
they'll hold the standard they'll hold
the standard of a joke of comedy against
me that's happened before too people
have taken statements like well you
can't take that statement literally just
like you can't take a statement I made
as a drunk Nick Nolte dressed as Rosa
Parks and a sketch series there's a
difference between the commentary and
the bits it's it's a little bit alarming
that you just used the word Western
civilization because as we were reading
on salon that's a dog whistle for white
supremacist yeah exactly
as we all know a white supremacist isn't
it that's my thing I mean it is I will
notice a slight media imbalance so the
interview with the BBC got you know all
this coverage that's fine totally fine
the week before the FBI arrested
somebody for threatening to kill me in
my family and it got five stories none
of them from national publication right
of course that's pretty just worth
noting yeah this does however one we had
we did the Crowder confronts of someone
who threatened to I think was at the one
who firebombed I wanted to slash our
tires with firebomb our van and we
confronted this person like hey by the
way really quickly we're not advocating
violence I just would really like it if
you take down this call to to bomb my
team in my van and the Austin Chronicle
the lady wrote like the taller
intimidating and muscular steven crowder
intimidates this poor small trans why
didn't you mention that this person
tried to
my manner said well I did mention that
you alleged that no no no here it is
here's the post like well I see that
you're alleging that no this person says
I did it it really is there really is a
disproportional response of the media
kind of as we've just covered this week
with the top hoaxes of 2019 we have
Brett Cavanaugh's our rapist the Russia
conspiracy hoax Jesse smaller and then
all of these other hate crimes hey
speaking of hate crimes uh clabe
obviously from my wonderful home state
of Michigan what's your this went back
and forth this week where she talked
about her was it set was it calming
feeling
yeah calming yeah yeah bombing uh when
she thinks about the Holocaust and
people said you know people were saying
conservatives had taken this out of
context when I read it in its entirety I
thought well that only makes it worse
because she said I get a sense I get a
calming feeling because I think of how
we provided a safe haven even though it
was against our will and obviously it
restrict us of our humanity that's like
a willing party here yeah what do you
think is the accurate read on that and
we removed the political ping-pong so I
don't think that her saying the
Holocaust gave her a calming feeling was
her saying yeah I feel calm about the
murder of six million Jews that's
obviously I want you saying the part of
it that's bad is when she completely
recast the history in a way that is not
only a historical but anti historical
the Palestinian Arabs were the original
inhabitants of the land that Jews have
no connection with the land the only
reason the State of Israel was created
was because of the Holocaust and then we
Palestinian Arabs we've worked to
integrate them and bring them at every
aspect of this is just sheer crap and
the problem is that it does back the
anti-semitic narrative that the Jews
have no place in Israel that they are
European colonialists implant and that
the Palestinian Arabs are the true
victims when it comes to the foundation
of the State of Israel despite the fact
that the Palestinian Arab leadership
sought to work with Hitler to impose a
final solution in the Middle East
despite the fact that the Palestinian
Arabs worked with the British Mandate to
prevent Jewish immigration to Israel to
British Mandate Palestine in the middle
of the Holocaust and there she is
proclaiming that the real victims in all
of this were that were the Palestinian
Arabs I mean again it plays into an
anti-semitic narrative because she's an
anti-semite but anybody who's reading
the calming Holocaust thing in the way
that I'd spoke about earlier that
obviously is in this raid it's it's it's
a mystery but I also do understand why
she said it what does she mean by
calming feeling I don't I think that you
John Pat [ __ ] had a great piece on
this a commentary he basically said she
thought she was saying something nice
saying something nice so when she says
the cheddar calming feeling she means
the Holocaust is bad but it makes me
feel better about all of the evils that
you did to me when I when I think about
the evils that were done to you and how
we were the victims of you healing from
that makes me feel better she thought
she was saying something nice but she's
an anti-semite that's not really
possible well I always thought to going
back to the tweets if someone were to
pull out one of my old tweets I think I
had a tweet there was a joke like a
modern Islamic it was about Islamic
governments Islam in 20 this might've
been 2016
basically Nazis who beat their wives and
people how dare you make that comparison
well let's take Hamas let's take these
organizations they believe you don't
think if they could exterminate Jews
right now if they had the ability to
wage a new Holocaust of course they
would and you know they beat their wives
Nazis I'm sure some of them did but it
was an exception not the rule
we can give them that I'm not even gonna
go here man people don't talk about the
Alliance feeling a lot of the Islamic
world that is certainly true well but
that is the that is the point of two
leaves idiocy and the fact is that that
Haj Amin al-husseini the the mufti of
Jerusalem he has like love letters from
Himmler in the middle of the Holocaust
talking about like we really hope to
wipe this Jewish threat off the planet
and thanks for your help Center that's
pretty great and they were playing a
game of telephone with tin cans in a
string with Henry Ford and he was like
what what can I get out on this and
people said yeah I guess that's true
very notorious anti someone do you know
that about four I didn't know that oh my
gosh yeah really some pretty rough when
you look no dude honestly I can't take
this interview I'm out I got I got to be
gone oh this another walk off
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey whoever comedian just keep in mind
that also have to represent this company
important welcome right angle
[Laughter]
now either you turn
[Music]
well you know what I hear you boys
needed it happen right on your ass deep
in your goal no longer gonna be able to
show my face in court okay continue
[Music]
if you don't join my club Maddie will
die
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
that's called the man who doesn't
realize enough you can't you can't purge
a flight helmet dummy those the Japanese
kamikaze who yeah purge you know how to
put when you scuba dive you pull it off
then you blow no this is Bill let's have
a really small head how does this fit no
over his headphones hold on let me get
this right by the way thank you so much
to Ben Shapiro um even though you know a
little bit move there what you can
expect I'm very uncomfortable do you
think I just stick with it and keep the
helmet on yeah we have to get ready by
the way cultural appropriation oh I
should let you know next we yes this
whole show is going to be hosted by none
other than Bernie Sanders that's true
not stuff the entire program guest
segments everything I'm going to be off
Bernie Sanders will be sub hosting and
then of course June cultural
appropriation months because get ready
to appropriate is to appreciate with
this is where we appropriate a new
culture every single every week every
time and bring you the wondrous
creations that cultures have to offer
across the world send in either here on
YouTube or tweet made us crowd earth the
cultures you want to see now we're up to
what it's been three years now yep three
years we've got three or four it's
either 12 in three of things okay we got
a laundry years and what it was was one
of those years had five yes do we have
five Thursday's was that the way it
worked out I mean I don't know I don't
know but one we calendar every one week
one month we said oh no we have a neck
we forgot there was another Thursday in
June it's the last day and then I think
we just did we got lazy and beer Sweden
or something go look up cultural
appropriation month Sweden and see it
watch Sally Kohn get anatomy really
excited for next week a lot of big
pretty it was the really I just remember
the look for sick house is fun until it
dawns what we're doing is really messed
up okay
credit closes in the silly hat too cute
man he pulls it off well that's a great
example people talk about privileged
girls where you know giant sunglasses
they look cute guys wear them they look
like they're [ __ ] really tries to
cover up a bender you wear that helmet
it's still cute it's disgusting I wear
it I look like that too
like it's I look like it's less you get
to sit over there it's a [ __ ] crash
helmet
I look like there should be look like
those corners should be nerfed alright
so I'm closest I've talked about truly
living in your purpose we've talked
about that in the show quite a bit and
we get a lot of messages you know we do
the life advice to love tough love
segments here for those who are mug club
members we don't really upload them to
YouTube but um you know it's a good rule
of thumb and I was talking with with
Manny and Tim about this there's kind of
a rule if you cannot describe your
concept your business or your point of
view if you cannot give some on that
pitch in a couple of phrases you really
maybe haven't thought about it so well
so let me try and distill this good rule
of thumb and people talk about living in
their purpose how do they figure out
you'll find yourself invaluable to
someone else when you make yourself
invaluable to some someone else let me
put it really simply you want to find
yourself this is the term when your lot
get really really good at something
my friend Bryan Callen has talked about
that you want to you want to figure out
what you're about get excellent at
something make yourself irreplaceable
and by the way it doesn't have to be big
it doesn't have to be irreplaceable to a
ton of people okay you can make yourself
invaluable to your boss to your kids to
your employees to your church little
league because you're the best damn
coach I ever saw I don't know but
irreplaceable 'ti breeds trust and when
you find more people are entrusting you
with more responsibility that's when you
get to show people what your true
character is otherwise you never know
when someone says oh that that's you
need to get that done you need to get X
done or Y o give that to Bob no one does
it better it'll feel great but you'll
also be in the hot seat and there are
these sound bites that we hear all the
time you know you hear a lot of athletes
say this or like Oprah you know it's not
what it's not what you do when you win
that defines you but how you come back
from a loss or sometimes I've heard it
the other way too or they said well
losing is easy winning is hard staying
on top you figure out what you're made
of neither is true you want to find out
what you're made of you want to find out
who you are it's what you do with trust
when someone trusts you you are
effectively both signing a character
check think of it that way a character
check of accountability responsibilities
expectations he's signing the front
you're signing the back of it think of
every great athlete or world leader from
it could be from Wayne Gretzky something
as trivial as something like hockey to
Winston Churchill they were all defined
by their wins as much as their losses
it's not either scenario that defines
you but in both instances by the way
they were entrusted what's doing their
best someone trusts from leading people
to a Stanley Cup leading the team just
tell it to losing seasons that defined
Wayne Gretzky the failures of gallipoli
to the victory in World War two we talk
about Churchill these were people in
positions which carried great intrinsic
trust because of their expertise because
of their excellency and because they
could be counted on to do their best you
know who never gets entrusted with a
whole lot the mediocre the good enough
so if you can't explain it to me right
now in one phrase two phrases I'll give
you at most two phrases you haven't
thought about it hard enough about to
ask you a question okay you ready
what are you really good at think about
it what do others or what do you think
what should others entrust to you
specifically if you don't know all the
self-help books and silent retreats in
the world they're not gonna help you you
need to figure it out find out what
makes you excellent find out who trusts
you and what they trust you with you'll
find out who you are and that's
something you can control
alright I'll see you next week it's not
the stupid helmet it hurts it hurts it
hurts
[Music]